the test isn't whether you get the
greatest does this idea in the world the
first time out the test is whether you
keep learning as you go along what your
strengths are and what you can do for
your customers but you can bring
especially to the party okay so
delighting your customers is really
important how do you actually do it my
specific advice is you don't have to
look the part I mean I certainly never
have right you don't have to sound the
part you just have to find a way to put
your customers in a position to succeed
and good things happen
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation at 7:00 my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent adds something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message delight customers
over to you Warren Buffett Henry Ford as
you may know failed twice before he
started the Ford Motor Company in 1903 I
mean the the test isn't whether you get
the greatest does this idea in the world
the first time out the test is whether
you keep learning as you go along what
your strengths are and what you can do
for your customers what you can bring
especially to the party and to do that
you need a genuine a genuine desire day
in day out to delight the customer I've
never I've never seen a business I've
seen a lot of businesses but I've never
seen one that delights the customer that
that doesn't succeed I mean what you
want is that customer the next day when
they think do I want to rent a car or do
I want to buy some furniture what goes
through their mind
you know it's the place where they've
had a great experience um I don't know
what I paid for this type actually
probably if somebody gave it to me for
the purposes of the speech I will say I
I have no idea but what I or the shirt
I'm wearing other but I do know I will
remember how I was treated what I bought
it I mean you long forget about the
price but you never forget whether you
had a good experience or a porridge
furnace with the purchase experience
this is a fantastic clip I've watched a
lot of Warren Buffett content and I've
never heard him talking about delighting
customers before and so I'm really glad
he's bringing it up because I think too
many entrepreneurs focus just about the
business model that focus about how
they're gonna make money they focus on
revenue targets and profit targets and
they're thinking about the customer as
their next suit as they're walking in
the door where if you focus on the
customer winning then you will win if
you focus on the customer having a great
experience and feeling just immensely
satisfied when they walk out of your
store then you will win I just launched
a new course on my website called 2:54
with ideas for 254 days I will send you
a video around confidence that every
single morning if you watch the video
you will get more confidence so 30
seconds of five minutes every single
morning not a huge time commitment and a
pretty big benefit if you're gonna
actually be more confident by the end of
it it works I was on a hangout with some
friends of mine entrepreneurs telling
them what I was up to and really proud
about my idea but wanting feedback I
don't make this better and so many of
their feedback was around the business
model well if you collect email
addresses here's where you can sell them
and if you make affiliate deals with
other companies then you can make a lot
more money by doing this like I don't
care about any of that stuff I don't
want to talk business models at all if
the customer is happy if you guys are
loving the videos I will win there's
lots of ways for me to make money
there's lots of ways for me to win
that's not what I'm focused on help me
make the experience for the audience as
good as possible so that when you see
that email come in every single morning
you are happy you want to click on it
you
open it you miss it if that email didn't
come that morning if it went to spam a
bunch of you already wrote to me about
that if the email did not come through
check your spam because it is coming
every day my goal is to make the
experience amazing for the people coming
and feeling confident every single day
if I do that then I win because you are
winning same thing for my youtube
channel if I make great content that
people enjoy and want to come back to
want to subscribe there's a million ways
that I can win with that I'm not worried
about the business model how much money
I'm making in the short term what I care
about is that you guys are getting value
and so if you could switch it I'm not
saying money is not important it is the
business models insanely important I
think in business models I love business
models it's how I get off it's amazing I
get high on business models it's the
best it's just that number one believe
is number one the value is number one
caring about the customers you guys
having a fantastic experience and if
I've let you down with the quality of my
content and I deserve to lose I deserve
to be at 1.3 million subscribers and not
ten because the contents not good enough
everything needs to get better ok so
delighting your customers is really
important how do you actually do it my
specific advice is put yourself in the
shoes of your customers actually be the
customer I make videos that I want to
see I make videos that I'm proud of I
love that Warren Buffett is talking
about delighting customers I'm learning
from it I am my own audience if you are
your own audience and say would I buy
this is this shoe that I'm making
actually good or is it a piece of junk
that I'm selling just trying to make
money would you actually use the thing
are you actually proud of this put
yourself in your customers shoes go
through the entire experience and say
was this amazing it's actually not that
difficult it's just a mindset shift of
putting the customer first and
everything else afterwards the money is
important the business mile is important
the profit is important revenue streams
are important all of that is important
but what's more important is the
customer is the experience is a
word-of-mouth marketing you're gonna get
because of it it's just the right thing
to do if people love love love love love
love love love love
what you do your business will win
period in the story now I've got a
really special bonus clip that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know what
is one thing you're gonna add now to
your product offering to your service to
how you do business
- better delight your customers what is
one simple action that you are going to
do today to better delight your
customers leave it down the comments
below I'm curious to find out and when
you write it down you much more likely
to actually take action and do it so put
it in the comments thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of an espresso and enjoy
the bonus clip
[Music]
everybody's got ideas you know that's
that's the easy part
but customer what sale customer customer
happy yes or no sale customer customer
happy yes or no right sale because
everything just feeds that right
everything else is noise and if you and
part of that though so there is a part
beat of that right because one tenant of
good businesses always listen to your
customers right you always want to
listen but you don't always want to do
what they tell you right because the
customers job is to just is to make
their company successful right and when
they tell you what they need and what
they tell you what they want they're
typically thinking about the right here
and now they're not thinking about your
potential competitors they're not take
thinking about the future of your
organization so you have to also
innovate you have to differentiate so
you have to have be over out here
innovating differentiating understanding
you know how you fit within your
industry and how you can get ahead but
then you have to turn that into sales
customers customer happiness and so if
you can execute on those things things
typically work out well it's not well my
office is pretty my office always looks
like crap right I mean our offices now
we we have these very desks everywhere
I'm not you know you don't have to look
the part I mean I certainly never have
right you don't have to sound the part
you just have to find a way to put your
customers in a position to succeed and
good things happen this is a huge
mistake that people make in marketing
that so many newsletters are me what am
I thinking
visit if it lets you come look at me hey
I'm at an event hey buy my and whenever
we sit and write the newsletter we're
thinking about what is the most valuable
thing because somebody has actually
invited us into their inbox and that is
a critical question in marketing that
most people are not asking themselves or
spamming people and they're doing only
shits about them and they're not
thinking about why does somebody
subscribe to me and when we write that
newsletter that's why it is so
incredibly successful and why people
love it we're always thinking about does
this interest or help or enter
the person that's reading it and you
know anytime that it turns out to be too
much of us talking about us somebody on
the team catches it thank God because
there's nothing more annoying than
having somebody go on and on and on
about all that cool they're doing versus
thinking about what are some interesting
hacks and and and links and cool things
that we can introduce people to that
might improve their work or their life
do you think you should focus on making
something that you believe people want
or something that you want I definitely
think it should I would focus it should
be on something that that that people
want you on but but I think the the
nuance on this is you shouldn't there's
always a question whether you're making
the judgment or you're taking some
survey of people to make the judgment
and and so I'm very much in the Steve
Jobs camp of you want to have like this
ESP link to the population at large and
understand what they want better than
they understand themselves and I take
the view that people don't generally
know what they want and so if you ask
them surveys if you do market studies
you will not actually get get the right
answer and so so there is something
about sort of this inspired you know
information inspired intuition about
what what the world is a whole wants if
you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it don't you
believe it you act like I have Tulsa
what a wail out of a handcuffed
lightning though Thunder in jail now you
know I'm bad over the last week I
murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 2:54
confidence or every single day for two
hundred fifty four days I will be
sending you a video between thirty
seconds and five minutes long that you
start your morning with around making
you feel confident it's absolutely free
check out the link in the description
below to get access